kann man herr dr wimmer heute schon bei
seinem hausarzt einen test machen um zu
wissen ob man infiziert ist also der
test ist nicht banal
wir hatten von schon kurz darüber
gesprochen frau professor brinkmann und
ich es ist schon so dass das ein
komplexer test ist die nicht jedes labor
durchführen kann aber es gibt immerhin
ein test ja auch innerhalb von ein paar
stunden ergebnisse liefert also wenn man
wirklich jetzt auf der intensivstation
ist oder ist ein fall der schwierig ist
dann kann man den dort nutzen aber
dieser schnelltest dass ich sage ich dir
jetzt mal oder jetzt gehen morgen alle
zum hausarzt und sagen ja einmal so ein
bisschen durch mund vision und mal
gucken ob es habe oder nicht das ist
nicht so einfach bei natürlich vielen
menschen die momentan fieber und
erkältungssymptome haben also es laufen
sehr viele durch die gegend haben eben
erkältung und dass da auch mal nachts um
drei man irgendwie wach liegt und sie
gesagt wo gott ist das vielleicht dann
doch das corona weil ich ja gestern beim
chinesen essen war das ist eine ganz
berechtigte angst die da ist es nur
nicht so leicht zu entkräften
welche schäden richtet des körper in
virus an und sind die halbe im körper im
körper logischerweise welche schäden
richtete das virus im körper eines
menschen also dass wir sie so ganz banal
coronaviren machen normalerweise eine
erkältung man weiß sogar dass das virus
mittlerweile damals hoch tödlich ist
wahrscheinlich einfach schnupfen virus
ist also das was übrig geblieben ist das
mutierte er die ganze zeit bei dem
corona virus ist das tückische dass eine
virale lungenentzündung verursacht
werden kann also nicht bakteriell wo ich
antibiotika geben kann und schnell
heilen kann sondern viral und das heißt
die der körper kann versagen er kann zu
wenig sauerstoff bekommen das organ und
auch andere organe werden so geschädigt
dass ich tatsächlich intensiv pflicht
ich werde und momentan weiß man dass 25
prozent also ein viertel aller die eben
dann im krankenhaus sind deswegen auch
auf die intensivstation müssen und das
ist schon hart und daher kommt ja auch
diese hohe sterblichkeit der im
vergleich zu anderen erkrankungen schon
sehr hoch ist was kann ein erkrankter
nur damit wir das auch verstehen das
kann ein erkrankter tun kann man ihm
schon helfen heilen kann man ihn noch
nicht weil es eben den impfstoff noch
nicht gibt und impfstoffe ist auch
sozusagen zu spät also wenn jetzt das
virus hütet in meinem körper dann habe
ich kein problem
das heißt man kann eigentlich nur dem
körper helfen sich selbst zu helfen das
geht so weit dass man künstlich beatmet
werden muss dass das blut teilweise
außerhalb des körpers mit sauerstoff
angereichert
geehrt werden muss man die lunge das gar
nicht mehr schafft das eine dialyse
stattfinden muss also das geht wirklich
so weit dass der körper komplett auf
maschinen externen angewiesen ist das
ist so der krasseste fall aber es gibt
natürlich auch fälle die sind weniger
schlimm
in china geht man davon aus dass etwa
nur die hälfte überhaupt
krankheitssymptome zeigt oder auch
krankenhaus pflichtig wird also die
spannbreite ist wahnsinnig groß und das
macht natürlich auch sehr schwer
einzuschätzen so und jetzt sagen sie
ersparen wir in deutschland sind gut
vorbereitet haben unsere behörden haben
unsere krankenhäuser schon mal einen
solchen stresstest vergleichbar derzeit
zu china bestanden
der erste der ein viele wow effekt zum
beispiel wo wir auch ganz andere
zusammenhänge am ende aber aus
lebensmitteln jahr nach deutschland und
mit lebensmittel nach deutschland
gekommen aber die situation ja hatten
vor etwa zehn jahren und das war ja auch
einen stresstest für für uns alle dass
ich meine ja auch mit gut vorbereitet
ist dass sie haben wir in bayern gesehen
also die weltgesundheitsorganisation die
gerade erwähnte hat ja auch noch mal
sehr positiv anerkannt wie wir in
deutschland und vor allem noch in bayern
umgegangen sind mit den infektionen und
das ist ja vor allem auch eine
anerkennung für die behörden und die
verantwortlichen vor ort was halt
wichtig ist es schnell eben eine
infektion tatsächlich dann auch zu
verifizieren durch die testung die
mittlerweile in allen uni kliniken
eigentlich im grunde auch möglich ist
und nach und nach dann auch in anderen
kliniken dass wir dann sehr schnell die
kontaktpersonen ausfindig machen das ist
ja genau das was jetzt in bayern
passiert ist und weiter passiert man
immer weitere kreise zieht wer hat mit
wem dann kontakt noch gehabt und
möglicherweise weitere infektionen
ausgelöst und dann immer die dann auch
identifiziert und bei positiven
testergebnis dann entsprechend auch
behandelt so jung unsere krankenhäuser
lehrern ausgestattet dafür auch eine
größere zahl von corinna patienten zu
behandeln
wir könnten auch war zumal ist ja nicht
nur superinfektion zu einer
isolierstation sein muss sondern nach
allem was wir derzeit wissen eben auch
eine reguläre intensivstation damit mit
der situation umgehen kann so wie wir es
ja auch in schwabing sehen können wir
auch mit größeren zahlen umgehen klar
bedeutet es ab einer gewissen
größenordnung
logisch mit zusätzlichen patienten dann
auch ein stress wenn sie sich so gerade
so genannten haben und eine
herausforderung für alle im jeweiligen
krankenhaus
aber ich finde es auch wichtig weil wir
haben jetzt gerade 14 55 der infektion
ihre inhalte in radio gemeldet sind den
zuschauern noch mal in eine 5 der
infektion die auch mit dem gerade
gezeigten webasto fall die situationen
zusammenhängt und die vier jedenfalls
die wir schon hatten die sind im moment
symptomfrei die sind sagte der
behandelnde arzt in der pressekonferenz
putzmunter und ich meine wenn man das
mal einordnet bis jetzt vier dann jetzt
fünf infizierte in deutschland vier
davon symptomfrei und putzmunter
da wünsche ich mir halt manchmal dass
das wenn ich so lese was bei facebook
und sozialen medien der russe seinen
theorien dass das hat aber auch mal
wahrgenommen wird wie momentan die
empfänger in deutschland
die situation ist das entscheidende
deswegen sind wir gut vorbereitet ist
schnell die infektionskette zu
unterbrechen unterbrechen
gesundheitswesen wie unseres kaders
jetzt wollen sie 90 deutsche
staatsbürger aus wo haben nach
deutschland fliegen darum bemüht man
sich seit letzter woche jetzt für
samstag ist ein flug nach frankfurt
angekündigt um insgesamt 90 deutsche
heer zu bringen wird es bei samstag und
frankfurt bleiben also gibt es jetzt
diese fluggenehmigung von den chinesen
ist die auswärtigen amt die
bundesregierung bemüht sich sehr
intensiv das jetzt zu finalisieren mit
den chinesischen partnern zählen sondern
zu viele jetzt nicht das thema sein erst
an der stelle jedenfalls sondern wir
müssen ja auch start und landerechte
schlicht und ergreifend haben die
chinesen die chinesischen behörden
daneben auch in der kooperation und das
zweite ist dass wir schnellstmöglich und
so landsleute zurückholen wollen aber
eben auch gut vorbereitet da kommen ja
dann 90 um die 90 bis 100 nach
deutschland aus wo an aus der stadt die
sozusagen nach jetzigen erkenntnissen
der staat das infektionsgeschehen es ist
die derzeit abgesperrt ist und zum
schutz derjenigen die da kommen deren
direkten umfeld aber auch der
gesamtbevölkerung
wollen wir dann eben auch eine zentrale
unterbringung während der
inkubationszeit also der ersten zehn bis
14 tage um einfach sicherzustellen
alle die die kommen werden symptomfrei
sein das ist auch eine voraussetzung die
chinesen machen nachvollziehbarer weise
aber trotzdem müssen wir sicherstellen
dass niemand die infektion nicht
mitbringt wenn er sehen dass wir zügig
oder sie behandeln können und das wollen
wir ihn sicher unterstellen sie sicher
oder wollen es sicher stellen nur auch
noch einmal zum verständnis wer hat in
einem solchen serie solchen fall welcher
minister hat dann eigentlich den hut auf
also wer legt fest dass die erst mal in
quarantäne sprich in eine kaserne kommen
was nun feststeht wer legt evakuierungen
fest wer hat den mut auf wird zum ersten
quarantäne heißt nicht leicht immer
kaserne
wir haben nur in diesem fall in diesem
fall wenn wir müssen ja für 90 leute
jetzt mussten wir zügig einfach eine
unterbringung möglich mache die
natürlich auch einzelzimmer ein anderes
beinhaltet aber auch nicht mitten in der
stadt oder ein dorf ist und da war eben
jetzt in der kürze der zeit und auch in
der angemessenheit das jetzt alles das
level der wahl soll die entscheidung
über die über die eine solche
unterbringung und die verpflichtung dazu
and macht die behörde vor ort also in
diesem fall zum beispiel wäre im ersten
moment beim verlassen des flughafens das
gesundheitsamt in frankfurt mehr
zuständig die sehr sehr erfahren sind
weil eben mit dem internationalen
flughafen frankfurt da viel erfahrung im
umgang mit den unterschiedlichen wir
haben auch am flughafen frankfurt
richtig kapazitäten sogar am flughafen
für alle möglichen fälle weil wir mit
allem rechnen müssen an so einem
internationalen flughafen
das sind die behörden vor ort zum
beispiel aber eine anordnung wie ich sie
gemacht habe dass alle die in aus china
in deutschland landen müssen im flugzeug
schon die kontaktdaten der passagiere
für die nächsten 30 tage gibt es
formulare für daneben ausfüllen lassen
einsammeln und entsprechend dann
bewahren als wir haben jeder unsere
zuständigkeit auf den unterschiedlichen
ebenen entscheidend ist ja dass wir gut
kooperieren und es gibt täglich manchmal
stündlich auf den unterschiedlichsten
ebenen telefonkonferenzen zwischen bund
und ländern und allen zuständigen
behörden
das funktioniert gut und aller welt
dr wimmer frau dr frau professor
brinkmann wenn die deutschen jetzt aus
wohin am wochenende eingeflogen werden
ist es dann nicht schon zu spät
also ich finde dass wir haben so viel
dusel momentan und so viel glück das man
wirklich sagen kann wir kommen derzeit
einem blauen auge davon das heißt das
sind eben 90 deutsche denen geht es
relativ gut
wir haben aber auch tatsächlich ein fall
der kritisch ist das nämlich dieses
virus sich von einem menschen zum
menschen übertragen hat und die frage
wie geschehen sodass ist dort geschehen
da sind jetzt auch 90 unter quarantäne
und ich kann dir sagen aus meiner zeit
in der notaufnahme ende alleine schon in
der nacht und sie haben wirklich gut zu
tun dass die herzinfarkte und
schlaganfälle haben die pause nur weil
das 90 menschen mit einer ansteckenden
krankheit
das heißt da kommt zwei isoliert
richtige patienten und das kann der
notaufnahme schon in die knie zwingen
denn die zimmer sind ja alle belegt die
ist es ja alles voll auf die
isolierstation von dem wir sprechen
die sind ja nicht in berlin ist jetzt
sich der halbe bettenturm der charité
leer und wartet darauf dass man
irgendwann so ein fall eintritt sondern
deswegen ja auch kaserne soweit sie ihn
auch zum glück noch relativ gut riet er
schon da sind wir erst mal keine platz
können wir in die da kommen sondern
bürger und bürgern dass die bundeswehr
das zur verfügung steht aber dass er
sogar das glück von dem ich spreche die
kommen aus einer hochrisiko region und
werden das große glück dass es ihn
einigermaßen gut geht
die chinesen ich habe heute auch noch
mit ein paar chinesischen kontakten
telefoniert die sammeln ja nun anders
daten und die wissen schon längst im zug
werden neben ihm saß die frage ist ja
dass wir das jetzt sammeln ist richtig
und korrekt aber was ist denn mit der
mitarbeiterin die aus china gekommen ist
wer saß dann neben der findet man das
heute noch mal eben so easy peasy raus
und das ist schon schwerer
und das große große problem ist eben
wenn es dann mal einmal wirklich
schwieriger wird und wenn jetzt mal bei
den statistiken bleiben ist gehen wir
davon aus von den 90 hätten mal die
hälfte tatsächlich jetzt die erkrankung
die infektion dann wird es statistisch
davon einer sterben das muss man sich
mal klar machen und momentan haben wir
einfach wirklich das glück auf unserer
seite
das kann ganz schnell kippen und die whu
ruft ja nicht mal eben einen globalen
notstand aus den hat sie bei saas
ausgerufen weil sich das
krankenhauspersonal weltweit immer mehr
infiziert hat und was man auch sagen
muss wir haben mittlerweile die zahl von
saas was er wirklich kritisch war
überschritten also die infektionsrate
ist ja schon drüber seit gestern
dh
das ist nichts was man eben ab tun kann
sondern das ist ich finde ein wirklich
großes problem wo man auch jetzt noch
gar nicht sagen kann das wird schon so
und so sein
das kann in alle richtungen gehen also
in mainz sind schon mal wichtig tut
keiner irgendetwas ab sondern wir gehen
sehr wachsam und sehr vor der situation
um
das finde ich erst mal schon mal richtig
ich bin zum zweiten auch wichtig in
diesem jahr sind schon bestätigt 50
menschen leider in deutschland an grippe
gestorben
es geht hier nicht darum irgend wie die
dinge zu relativ wenig hinter sehr sehr
ernst weil ein neuer virus von dem wir
noch nicht genau wissen wer das genau
mit dem auf sich hat das muss man sehr
sehr ernst nehmen aber ich finde es eben
auch schon wichtig die dinge immer
entstellt nicht relativieren einordnen
und dann sende und am ende eben auch
angemessen angemessen mit den dingen
umgeht und deswegen aber gleich gehts
gleich nicht hängt ja es funktioniert ja
gar nicht das problem bei der grippe ist
ja dass sie ja gar nicht faktisch wissen
wieviel grippetote gibt es denn das ist
eine schätzung ich hab gerade auch mit
den 20 uhr robert koch institut ist eine
schätzung sie wissen
pro jahr 20.000 pro jahr so diese
schätzung kann aber auch ein feuer bei
null liegen
und jetzt jetzt gucken sie mal ins labor
und schauen mal wie viel sind dann
bestätigt labortechnischen laut robert
koch institut bestätigt dann sind das x
200 x 1700 das korreliert aber überhaupt
nicht mit der anderer zahl das heißt
selbst in einem nuller jacken sie 200
bestätigte fälle im labor haben und bei
20.000 haben sie vielleicht auch nur 200
bestehen totalität weil es ausgerechnet
die die oder frau bringt man kann es
erscheint was erklären aber die wie es
grob ausgerechnet wird ist man guckt
sich an wie viele menschen sterben in
einer gewissen zeit
somit hat man eine grippewelle und guckt
wie viel sind denn jetzt gestorben und
sagt die differenz also will ich ganz
grob gesagt die differenz in die grippe
toten
das ist ein bisschen banal und sagt das
robert-koch-institut es ist eine
schätzung so und das ist eine andere
mortalitätsrate und wir sprechen hier
von bis zu 20 prozent der deutschen die
im jahr eine grippe haben das ist auch
ein bisschen was anderes als ein paar
tausend menschen wovon schon ein paar
hundert verstorben sind das sind andere
relationen und das kann man nicht
einfach in einen pot schmeißen müssen
wir schon mal wichtig weil ich verstehe
die ganze hektik und herangehensweise
gerade nicht die herr doktor wimmer hier
macht ja auch keiner was in einen pot
geschmissen und nicht abgetan ich wäre
sehr dankbar wenn sie so in der frage
wie sie
mit der wortwahl rangehen das vielleicht
etwas anders machen dafür finde ich ist
die situation zu ernst und die frage
auch die sich viele bürgerinnen und
bürger im stellen das heißt dass wir uns
in deutschland und in europa zu ernst
und deswegen bitte ich einfach dafür um
das portal auch gegenseitig das müssen
bei einem grippevirus kann in manchen
jahren eine traurige mortalität zahl bei
20.000 landen da muss man frau professor
weg bringt man wissen dass es aber auch
zwei millionen infizierte gibt also man
hat auch ein ganz anderes verhältnis von
infizierten menschen zu todesfällen
da helfen sie uns bei der aufklärung ja
ich würde auch gerne ein paar dinge
etwas relativieren die gesagt die sie
gesagt haben zum einen würde ich auch
einmal betonen die 90 personen die
eingeflogen kommen sind nicht schwer
krank und die kommen nach frankfurt und
frankfurt ist extrem gut aufgestellt
habe ja nur sagen als auch die ersten
patienten und die kollegen dort in der
virologie sind absolute gut aufgestellt
so dass haben wir abgehakt jetzt die
grippe die grippe ist im moment
tatsächlich auch ein problem denn wir
haben grippesaison ja nach dem
jahreswechsel geht die grippesaison groß
und die ist und vollem lauf ja und da
muss man auch sagen da sind die
notaufnahmen mit teilweise auch
beschäftigt und auch die
intensivmedizinisch mit diesen patienten
beschäftigt und es ist von daher kann so
gutes timing
mit diesem virus jetzt aus asien das
wäre ein bisschen später etwas besser
gewesen aber trotzdem kommen wir damit
werden wir damit klarkommen was nicht
dazu bringt nochmal an alle zu
appellieren denn man fragt sich ja was
kann ich jetzt eigentlich tun da muss ja
nicht immer panik machen und sagen gott
sondern was kann ich eigentlich gerade
als normalbürger tun dass hier mal ein
bisschen ruhe einkehrt und grippe
impfstoff auch die grippe impfung
tatsächlich dann haben wir das schon mal
wieder zu sehen
das wäre so nicht gemacht sondern dass
alle länder eck für dem
gesundheitssystem helfen und den
patienten die wir dann durch das neue
virus habe
da haben wir die impfung nicht haben
schon so und es ist sehr wichtig zu
unterscheiden dass man sich nicht mit
einer grippe infiziert hat sondern
gegebenenfalls mit diesem virus weil
erst mal treten identische symptome auf
das machte sie also problematisch
wandern die kurz nach china da werden
jetzt 56 millionen menschen in
quarantäne gestellt städte werden
abgeriegelt regierungen werden
abgeriegelt wie sinnvoll ist das
eigentlich aus ihrer sicht weil da ja
kranke und gesunde menschen zusammen
sind
das ist im moment eine drastische
maßnahme aber die wird hoffentlich
tatsächlich erfolg zeigen das werden wir
in ein bis zwei wochen sehen denn diese
quarantäne ist verhängt seitdem
korrigiert sie mich bestimmt
dreiundzwanzigster januar
und da müsste man was man dadurch
versucht ist dass die menschen erst mal
alarmiert sind und wissen es ist es
ernst und ich muss mich dementsprechend
entsprechend verhalten ich kann nicht
mehr nach deutschland fliegen ich muss
zu hause bleiben und ich muss auch meine
sozialen kontakte reduzieren denn durch
die sozialen kontakte kommt es zur
ansteckung
und wenn ich das jetzt wenn es jetzt
gelingt in china das zu reduzieren die
ansteckungsrate dann sind wir in großen
schritt weiter die chinesen sagen sie
liegt bei 1 zu 25 also ein chinesisch
deck 25 menschen an das ist tatsächlich
auch eine relativ hohe zahl die auf 1
bekommen wäre es super dass das wort ist
schon ein paar mal gefallen
beim saas virus 2002 haben die
chinesischen behörden viel falsch
gemacht und sie wollten diesmal ganz
viel besser machen
saß das schwere akute respiratorische
syndrom eine lungen infektionskrankheit
erstmals beobachtet im november 2002 in
der chinesischen provinz guandong
doch die staatsführung vertuschte die
gefahr informierte weder die bevölkerung
noch die weltgesundheitsorganisation mit
fatalen folgen
das virus verbreite sich weltweit auch
klinikpersonal trug dazu bei
sie wussten es nicht besser erst monate
später änderte die chinesische führung
ihre informationspolitik china verliert
weltweit vertrauen nicht durch die
krankheit sondern durch die notorische
lügerei offiziell erkannten 8000 96
menschen an saas 774 starben fast alle
in asien fast neun monate dauerte es bis
die weltgesundheitsorganisation
entwarnung gab
inzwischen gilt erreger als vernichtet
felix diesmal soll alles besser sein
behörden wissenschaftler auch politiker
in aller welt müssen sich darauf
verlassen können dass sie präzise
informiert werden können sie das also ja
es läuft alles besser definitiv als 2003
aber man kann auch sagen 2003 war eine
riesen katastrophe wie die chinesische
führung damals vorgegangen ist also
insofern ja es läuft besser das läuft
sicherlich nicht alles ideal man kriegt
ja auch bilder zu sehen wie schwierig
das teilweise ist aber andererseits muss
man natürlich auch sehen das ist eine
drastische maßnahme und ob die
übertrieben ist das weiß man
letztendlich erst hinterher vielleicht
ist es total angemessen und wie sie das
ja auch schon gesagt haben solange man
nicht weiß wie vanderbeek überhaupt
erreicht ist und wann man das wirklich
unter kontrolle hat halte ich es so
richtig das sind da auch so drastisch
vorgegangen wird
ok also insofern ja also besser als bei
salz besser
gibt es eine erklärung saß jetzt dieses
neue corona virus warum solche schlimmen
erkrankungen oder solchen ihren ursprung
in china haben ja also es ist sicherlich
einfach der dichte der menschen also
alleine wo hahn hat elf millionen
einwohner die provinz hat 80 millionen
damals als saas in südchina der ausbrach
bandung ist bekannt dafür wie eng und
vor allem auch wie die ländliche
bevölkerung wie sehr die mit
mit vielen tieren ist also also auf
engsten raum quasi zusammenleben also
insofern ist es sicherlich kein zufall
dass viele solcher viren dann auch aus
china kommen ich muss allerdings auch
sagen es hat sich doch auch eine menge
getan in dem sinne dass saas das hygiene
bewusstsein seit saß in china doch
inzwischen ein ganz anderes ist also wer
jeder der mal in den 90er jahren in
china war wird sich daran erinnern wie
in welchem schmutzigen und
unhygienischen zustand doch öffentliche
toiletten waren die küchenhygiene und so
weiter und ich glaube das hat sich schon
auch mit zunehmendem wohlstand
zunehmender entwicklung zu auch mehr
wissen hat sich das innerhalb doch in
letztendlich verhältnismäßig kurzer zeit
hat sich da doch einiges getan
und ehrlich gesagt halte ich das ja wenn
man sich jetzt auch den verlauf anguckt
des letzten monats ist es da finde ich
das fast schon beeindruckend wie schnell
einiges vonstatten gingen also die
globalisierung in dem sinn ist war
schuld daran dass sich das auch so
kurzer zeit dann aus weiter ausbreiten
konnte
aber man muss dieser globalisierung in
dem sind auch zugute halten
wieviel wissensaustausch ist seitdem
gegeben hat also ich sage nur wenige
tage später wurde der virus in bereits
identifiziert es war ein deutsches team
der dürftigen diesen diese testern
entwickelt haben jetzt in den letzten
tagen haben die australischen
australische wissenschaftler zumindest
die voraussetzung geschaffen wie man
diesen virenstamm auch vermehren kann
also voraussetzungen dafür überhaupt ein
impfstoff zu entwickeln und jetzt wird
parallel weltweit in ganz vielen
regionen an einem impfstoff gearbeitet
das ist auch ein vorteil ab da so ist
total beeindruckend und den eben sind
muss man auch sagen also da hat sich
nicht nur also china hat der welt viel
zu verdanken momentan dass das
und das so viel hilfe kommt dann kommt
aber man muss auch sagen der die welt
hat auch china zu verdanken dass es
nicht noch schlimmer schon weltweit sich
verbreitet hat als es derzeit der fall
so professor brinkmann zoonosen heißen
krankheiten die von einem tier auf den
menschen übertragen werden und ganz
grundsätzlich ist das auch bei diesem
corona virus der fall heißt das dass
immer irgendwann in der kette der
übertragung ein mensch ein tier gegessen
haben muss das wissen wir nicht genau
wie es dazu gekommen ist was bei diesen
coronaviren wir sind sehr weit
verbreitet im tierreich in säugetieren
und vögeln und zu den säugetieren
gehörten auch die fledermäuse und wir
wissen durch arbeiten von vielen corona
virus experten dass viele fledermäuse
kroner viren in sich tragen
und da kommt es immer wieder zu
übertragung auf den menschen
dabei saß und im falle von merz war das
ja auch es ist wird es auch wäre es war
im nahen osten genannt nahen osten gehen
da kennt man auch das reservoir des
houston die kamele und dromedare und war
ich jetzt genau und kongressen genau
dann kommt es zu übertragen auf den
menschen wo zu losen oft aufhören ist
dann tatsächlich der mensch es kommt
also nicht immer dazu das ist für
menschen dann zu menschen übertragen
während diesem konkreten fall jetzt aber
haben und noch mal zum verständnis der
drb bola in afrika märz im nahen osten
jetzt in china corona und vorher saß
warum passieren solche sachen eben
weniger in europa oder weniger in
nordamerika warum haben sie der seltener
ihren ursprung ja also die theorie als
sind der theorie muss man sagen ja man
kann es nicht mal genau festnageln aber
gerade die fledermaus ist so ein
bisschen der bösewicht von einem man
muss sagen dass ein viertel aller
säugetiere auf der welt sind fledermäuse
man sieht sie nur natürlich nicht so und
je näher wir den auf die pelle rücken
desto wahrscheinlicher ist es dass auch
mal was über springt also die fledermaus
hat sogar eine ziel eine vielzahl von
viren die für uns gefährlich sein können
und viele andere tiere gefährlich sein
können die bei ihr aber gar nichts macht
so und dann
es gibt aber ein virus zb also tollwut
das ist dann auch gefährlich für die
fledermaus und wenn man dann auf einem
markt natürlich diese fledermäuse sehr
eng zusammen hält mit anderen tieren
oder sie sogar verspeisen würde da muss
man aber auch ganz doll aufpassen was
jetzt für fotos online kursieren und was
eigentlich sozusagen auch auf dem
chinesischen markt passiert dies eine
fotoshow junge frauen die fledermaus
suppe ist das ist nie in china
geschossen worden das ist ganz woanders
auch im rahmen dieser kochshow aber was
kann man alles essen also da muss man
überlegen welche bilder passen auch zu
der geschichte
aber das problem ist eben dass die
fledermaus viele sozusagen regel in sich
trägt und wenn wir in den lebensraum
eindringen dann kann es eben auch sich
übertragen warum die so viele
krankheitserreger tragen ist wohl auch
weil sie ja tonnenweise insekten und
schädlinge von uns fern halten und die
sind aber dann wohl eher der ursprung
des erregers der ganz ursprüngliche
ursprung ähnliche epidemien in
deutschland
herr sparen sind damit also eher
auszuschließen oder müssen wir auf so
etwas tatsächlich auch vorbereitet sein
frau professor brinkmann sagt und auch
andere virologen diese pläne für die
pandemie sollen wir nicht nur raus holen
wir sollten sie tatsächlich haben die
sollten wir haben und wir müssen
natürlich vorbereitet sein zumal wir
insofern als weltgemeinschaft ja das
blaue auge wenn sie so wollen haben weil
dieser wie roh ist jetzt erstmal so ist
wie er es mit dem kann man ja noch
umgehen auch in der frage wer übertragen
wird und was er bis jetzt an insgesamt
verläuft zeigt bei aller dramatik ja
noch wenn man mal so ein steigt mit
virologen was so alles denkbar wäre ganz
andere szenarien und deswegen geht es
natürlich darum vorbereitet zu sein ich
hab gerade ehec schon genannt vor zehn
jahren wäre es richtig erinnere war
hatten wir über 50 todesfälle auch in
deutschland damals das war ja schon eine
situation eben auch hier die die gezeigt
hat dass das sich eben auch für uns
ergeben kann ob jetzt sozusagen
ausgelöst wird und startet in
deutschland oder europa oder
durch internationalen reiseverkehr und
warenverkehr das kam mir damals durch
lebensmittel nach durch die straßen
generell die sprossen sind wir natürlich
als ein land das vernetzte svi nicht
viele andere an vielen stellen auch für
den stall in welche orte auch zumindest
zur wachsamkeit angehalten heisst und
das haben wir eben auch gelernt in den
letzten jahren durch all diese pandemien
wie andere länder auch dass man
natürlich manche dinge auch üben muss
dass es pläne geben muss dass es
überhaupt diese diese regelhafte
koordinierung zwischen bund und ländern
gibt es das robert koch institut
diese zentrale rolle auch gerade spielen
kann das hat sich alles erst in den
letzten 20 jahren eben geschichten
entwickelt von professor brinkmann sie
müssen uns auch noch mal erklären wir
wissen dass dieses virus mutiert dass es
sich verändert wie erfolgreich kann man
einen impfstoff entwickeln wenn es sich
ständig verändert und wie lange wird es
brauchen meint sie jetzt das was gerade
kursiert das kochen es gibt ja viele ja
dieses das neue kann man also ja das
sind viren die tatsächlich gerne
mutieren und auch untereinander sich mal
austauschen wenn das virus von der katze
zusammentrifft mit dem aus der
fledermaus es kann passieren was man
aber auch beobachtet ist bei denen bei
diesem virus vor allem dass es sich
erstaunlich wenig verändert und das ist
ganz beruhigend auch ja also und auch
wenn es sich verändern soll so heißt das
nicht immer dass es zum schlechteren für
uns ist sondern dass wir uns schlecht
den mann entwickelt und sequenziert dann
tatsächlich auch hilft braucht ungefähr
drei monate oder eher ein jahr braucht
er ein bisschen länger braucht er das
tatsächlich der fall ist ein impfstoff
wird jetzt bei dieser berg zum ausdruck
er zu spät kommen das alles ist in drei
jahre drei monate ein jahr das eine
sozusagen weil man erste möglichkeiten
hat dann auch in studien zu gehen dass
nach drei bis fünf monaten sagen die
fachleute kann es gelingen muss nicht
sich ja auch immer daran wie gut man
dann mit dem material umgehen kann da
würde man sich allerdings manchmal bei
der frage dann doch noch ein stück mehr
transparenz
wünschen und zusammenarbeit mit den
kollegen in china auch und das haben wir
bei ebola jetzt auch gesehen muss man ja
am ende die studien auch machen da wo
der ausbruch ist weil sie müssen ja ein
ende dann in der situation aufzeigen
der unterschied ist aber dann konnte man
auch schon in der studie
beim ausbruch in eppelborn unterschied
machen also es wird sich dann über die
monate entwickeln aber für das was wir
gerade alles sehen und für die patienten
kommen natürlich ein impfstoff
offenkundig erstmals zu spät aber
vielleicht funktioniert er für den
nächsten vielleicht funktioniert er für
die nächsten noch schneller dr wimmer
als das virus verbreiten sich gerüchte
im internet sie haben das schon
angedeutet die im medizinbranche die
pharmaindustrie will milliarden
verdienen bill gates hat angeblich ein
patent auf dieses virus er hat es
angeblich erfunden
im grunde ist die situation viel
schlimmer als hier heute alle sagen
wie geht man damit um wo ist eine gute
abwägung zwischen einem berechtigten
zweifeln und eine verschwörungstheorie
also man muss ja sagen woher komm
verschwörungstheorien im kern das ist ja
oft fallen misstrauen da ist das heißt
ich fühle mich von den regulären medien
oder auch von dem start wo ich wohne
lebe wie auch immer im stich gelassen
und bin dann halt auch sehr empfänglich
für andere theorien und china hat das
erkannt die haben damals ja bei sars
2003 nicht besonders gut kommuniziert
und dann ist es natürlich auch einfach
zu sagen geht nicht immer um welche
wahrheit gibt es dennoch
da wurde viel geändert da wird hart
daran gearbeitet trotzdem muss natürlich
auch ein staat darauf achten was kann
jetzt endlich kommunizieren man muss am
ende wenn man der konsument davon ist in
den sozialen medien halt auch selber ein
bisschen aufpassen
manchmal passiert ist eher durch zufall
das mannschaftsfoto kenne ich doch schon
von woanders oder der text ist komisch
geschrieben oder ich weiß wäre das
gepostet hat das ist halt nicht so ganz
einfach ja es ist halt tatsächlich
schwierig weil mit emotionen gespielt
wird und wenn ich schon angst habe und
ich habe sorge um meine verwandten oder
meine weise nicht meine nichte oder eine
bekannte ist in china und studierter und
jetzt habe ich schon die sorge und die
angst ich bin emotional schon angreifbar
und dann kommt noch so was und ob dann
ist das natürlich auch sozusagen leicht
umgesetzt dass ich noch mehr angst habe
und dann verbreitet sich aus
weil ich mich heute mit unterhalten aber
auch mit mitarbeitern von webasto und
was die berichten was zum teil die
familie erlebt die kinder in den
kindergärten die irgendwie von den
anderen kids zum teil aber auch zum teil
durch unsicherheit bei den erzieherinnen
oder bei den lehrern in der schule
irgendwie an die seite gesetzt werden
oder oder dachten wir uns sein erzählte
der kfz mechaniker hat sich geweigert
sein auto zu reparieren eines webasto
beschäftigten also dann merkt man ihnen
dass sie keine verschwörungstheorien
sondern unsicherheit ängste sorgen und
gerade virus das glaube ich ganz tief
einfach so in den menschen hinein dass
die die frage was ist das was passiert
da das unbekannte
also das hat mich hat mich ja schon
schon sehr verwundert was die da erleben
ist sagt aber eben auch eine menge aus
wie wichtig informationen und dann am
ende eben auch 30 immer wieder gerade
von unseren seiten staatlicherseits
regierung sei es möglichst viel
transparenz und information aber eben
auch in der angemessenheit zulage zu
reden aufmerksam aber dann eben doch
auch mit der nötigen gelassenheit
solange sie zu jedenfalls angebracht